[Musique]
on attrape plus de mouches avec du miel
qu avec du vinaigre et donc je suis le
boute-en-train
je raconte une histoire les gens ne s'en
lasse jamais parce qu'ils s'identifient
à eux mêmes à ce genre d'histoire je
suppose et nous aimons entendre parler
de nous tant que les personnages qu'on
retrouve dans ces histoires sont ou non
mais pas nous celle là sera décisive
[Musique]
je suis basterds buster kraft tout six
coups et chargé
[Musique]
apparemment oui
tu as quelque chose à dire avant que la
sentence soit exécutée la sentence mais
quelle sentence à aa à aa
[Musique]
ici dans le grand ouest la situation
peut vite dégénérer
v ozymandias soit des rois
ce type est vraiment sûr pas pareil a
plus qu'à chercher tu crois pas
[Musique]
première fois